wer weiß schon von morgen sind
jeden tag das sind
wer
heute morgen sind immer und wieder aufs
neue beginnt
wir sind in oberammergau mitten in den
bergen eine stunde autofahrt von münchen
entfernt ganz genau
ein sehr schöner ort hier bestehen hier
vor dem laden von leonard heldrich ein
echter bildhauermeister und
holzschnitzer von der alten schule
untergehen so hallo servus sie sind also
der erhältlich leonard ja genau und es
ist gerade die neuestes werk oder das
ist mein neues weg das heißt man ist ein
auftrag wofür eine kirche herum entsteht
muss der drei so große zu große tafeln
machen bestimmt richtig viel arbeit oder
vier fünf wochen können sie machen es
aber schon viele viele jahre und werden
wahrscheinlich viele schöne skulptur nie
sagen wie viele sie in ihrem leben
gemacht haben und wir sind sehr viele
kleinere kunden
bei grippe ist etwas was immer am besten
zieht darf man dann doch einen relativ
großen kundenstamm kaufen das
hauptsächlich touristen oder sind es
einheimische touristen die kommentar zum
teil speziell her oder mittlerweile geht
es über internet benutzen mit eisen und
schlägel
dass seine von die größeren da gibt es
bis zu einem millimeter breite ganz klar
für mini teil des entwicklers kleine zu
rechnen beim großen es ein bisschen grob
aus aber hier sieht man schon da braucht
man sehr viel feingefühl dafür das ist
richtig sie machen alles alleine hier
also sie schmeißen den laden einerseits
muss er sich auf den verkauf kümmern und
sind aber nebenbei hier in der werkstatt
des richtiger sie sind bildhauermeister
liegt es in der tradition der familie
ich bin der zweite mein vater hat
begonnen noch einen krieg person ist
vertreten in der familie mein fahrrad
von golder arbeiten und so was
allerdings haben auch dekoartikel und
andere sachen zukäufe nur mit dem
eigenen handwerksbetrieb weil jedes teil
braucht seine zeit
nicht jeder preis ist durchsetzt war
würden sie uns so ein zwei handgriffe
zeigen wo wir auch mal irgendwie so
ausprobieren können ohne dass wir die
finger verlieren
die finger sind sehr nah das hat auch
struktur und sieht ich habe talent
es gibt einen haufen holz wieder unten
fertig was sagen sie prima talent oder
stellen sie mich ein okay dann nehme ich
das für meine mama mit erst bis bald